[Musique]
6 mois après les ameutes urbaines de
l'été 2023 l'heure est au bilan pour la
mairie d'Acher un plan de remboursement
a été proposé lors du conseil municipal
le 19 décembre interrogé par nos
confrèrees de C H8 actu le maire de la
ville Marc honoré a confié que
l'addition devrait monter autour de
300000 € pour les travaux de la mairie
l'assurance prendrait en charge une
partie des remboursements à hauteur de
200000 € une bonne nouvelle pour le
maire de la commune avéis ville à coublé
les deux hommes accusés d'avoir volé une
centaine de consoles ps5 chez Amazon ont
été incarcéré interpellé par la police
quelques jours auparavant parmi les
marchandises volées plus d'une centaine
de consoles après avoir avoué les fait
les deux suspects ont été incarcérés
dans l'attente de leur audience fixée au
31 janvier 2024 le préjudice total
s'éléverait à 150000 €. après les fêtes
de fin d'année les sapins de Noël font
l'objet d'une collecte spécialisée 5 en
evveline organise la collecte des sapins
de Noël en porte à porte pour les 12
communes du 5 au 15 janvier 2024 cette
tournée permet à chacun de ne pas avoir
à se déplacer seul restriction les
sapins avec de la neige artificielle ne
peuvent être
recyclés